something's happening to us
[Music]
we need to find the others i haven't
seen some of them for centuries
you hear that sprite
family reunion it's about time
it's a really interesting mix and having
10 characters we're a big slightly
dysfunctional family this is what the
end of the world looks like at least we
have front row seats well you know
what's never saved the planet you're
sarcasm
cersei she has the power to manipulate
mata and she's had a long-running on-off
relationship with icarus how long were
you together 5 000 years i guess you can
call that long term
icarus is the loyal soldier dad that
superman with the cape and you're
shooting laser beams out of your eyes
i don't wear a cape
fastest can assemble anything out of any
kind of technology there were more
deviants than you said well i'm sure
that was fun for you it
was athena she's the goddess of war
she can manifest different weapons
which was very fun
gilgamesh
he's a protector
his specialty is a strong punch
this is makari none of us has seen it
for centuries
sprite can create illusions
she's really sarcastic especially with
kingo
i would say kingo is
a little self-involved kingo demon vista
i've directed some things too
droog he's mind control he stands up for
what he believes in and that there
shouldn't be violence
don't we don't interfere in their wars
and then there is ajax she's kind of the
leader of the eternals her power is
healing
this planet and these people
have changed me
these superheroes
reflect the world we live in
everybody is unique and special
i think eternals is the most epic movie
that marvel has done and i really really
mean that
they're really gonna see a movie
unlike any they've ever seen before
[Music]
[Music]
you